Ці солдати щойно повернулися з передової.
Кілька днів відпочинку, тренування - і вони знову повернуться в окопи.
Ситуація там не змінюється кардинально, але бої не вщухають.
У мене таке відчуття, і не тільки в мене, що в них абсолютно нескінченні боєприпаси.
Це трошки… Англійською це frustrating.
Тим не менше ми тут стоїмо за свою свободу, за свою країну.
Я вважаю, що це набагато важливіше, ніж боєприпаси.
Це глибокий тил на Лиманському напрямку.
Лінія фронту в цьому регіоні залишається незмінною вже майже рік.
З настанням зими й погіршенням погоди рухатися вперед стане ще складніше.
Тут дуже дивна земля…
У мене таке відчуття, що вона вологу не поглинає, і стає дуже важко пересуватися.
Вона болотиста, глиняна.
Евакуація поранених з поля бою - теж частина тренувань.
Україна не розголошує статистику втрат.
Але існують побоювання, що чимало підрозділів виснажені й можуть втратити боєздатність.
Президент України Володимир Зеленський визнав, що контрнаступ ЗСУ не досягнув бажаних результатів.
За його словами, ЗСУ для цього бракує сил,
у той час як увага Заходу "переключилася" на конфлікт на Близькому Сході.
У нас нова фаза війни і це факт.
Війна складна. Зима в цілому це нова фаза війни.
Бо війна зимова відбувається не тільки на лінії фронту,
а й усередині міст через велику кількість застосування ворогом дронів,
через велику кількість застосування ракет, зокрема балістики тощо.
Тому зимова війна складна.
Танкісти, які тренуються у Запорізькій області, теж говорять про те, що війна змінюється.
І не лише через погоду.
У холодну пору року вести штурмові дії важче.
Плюс оскільки зараз змінилися правила війни,
то тепер уже такими колонами, де залучаються танки, БМП, нема сенсу проводити.
Тому що все розвивається - з'явилися FPV-дрони, дрони-камікадзе.
Ти не встиг виїхати, як тебе вже виявили,
і противник піднімає все, що в нього є, щоб знищити танк.
На бронетехніку, зокрема західну, ЗСУ робили ставку під час намагань прорвати російську оборону на півдні.
Танки й БМП зіткнулися з тисячами мін,
а також з російськими дронами.
У 2022 році українські військові першими почали
скидати боєприпаси з квадрокоптерів на позиції противника.
Ця стратегія дозволяла ефективно й дешево знищувати російську техніку.
Утім, РФ скопіювала цю тактику й наростила виробництво власних БПЛА.
Як усі знають, коли ти бачиш танк противника,
ти його намагаєшся знищити насамперед.
Бо це дуже сильна зброя, маневрена, з потужною гарматою.
Так само противник, коли бачить нас, так як ми заводили завжди піхоту,
ми перші заходили на передній край противника, ми перші проривали оборону
- це все робилося за допомогою танків.
Зараз уже мала ймовірність, що ти доїдеш до цього переднього краю.
Це треба розвивати РЕБ, глушити FPV-дрони,
щоб наносити нормальне вогневе ураження.
Попри все, згідно з останніми соцопитуваннями,
майже половина українців вірить в успіхи ЗСУ цієї зими.
На тлі ризику затяжної позиційної війни,
корупційних скандалів і критичних публікацій у західних ЗМІ,
якщо міжнародна підтримка України скоротиться, військові готові й надалі виконувати свою роботу.
Ми постійно готуємося, накопичуємо навички, розвиваємося.
Якщо буде команда проводити якісь штурмові дії - ми готові.
Це все за наказом відбувається.
Наступного року Україна витратить половину річного бюджету на оборону
- це рекордна частка.
Президент Зеленський наголосив, що сподівається на допомогу західних партнерів
у виробництві Україною власної зброї.
Утім, досі чимало повсякденних потреб армії
закриваються за рахунок "донатів" і приватних внесків.
А дедалі більше військових замислюються про те, що українці в тилу могли б робити більше.
Цивільні люди мають більше можливостей, але вони не хочуть це робити, вони втомилися.
Їм розповіли, що все класно, все чудово, вони собі й живуть.
А ми живемо тут. Тобто два паралельних світи, абсолютно паралельних…
У цьому світі багнюки й куль військові звикли не показувати розчарування.
Вони готуються до виснажливого "марафону" і сподіваються,
що країна, яку вони захищають, здатна його пройти.